NARRATOR: New York City, May
4, 2015, at Tech Crunch Disrupt
New York, an annual new
technologies conference,
US biotech start-up BioBots
launches a desktop 3D printer
for biomaterials,
which they use to print
a replica of van Gogh's ear.
Instead of plastic, special ink
is combined with biomaterials,
like collagen and
cultured cells,
to build living tissue
and human organs.
So right now, we're just at
the beginning of understanding
how to 3D print organs.
It's a process called
biofabrication.
So BioBots has created
a biofabrication
3D printer that can
print artificial tissue
and small organs.
In the future, what
we're going to see
are 3D printers that are
biofabricating our bodies
and our organs.
DAVID WILCOCK: You
could eventually
have printable noses,
lungs, ears, kidneys.
And in certain ways,
this technology
is so extreme that it
could make it democratic.
It could make it inexpensive.
So in the hands of skilled,
trained medical professionals,
it could be possible
in the future
to 3D print organs
for people out
of their own genetic material.
NARRATOR: Transhumanists
believe we may soon transcend
our biological limitations
as we embed machines
directly into our own bodies.
DARPA, the agency of the
US Department of Defense
responsible for the development
of emerging technologies
for use by the
military, is currently
designing neural
implants that will
improve cognitive speed and
memory retention in soldiers.
And in 2014, scientists at Seoul
National University in South
Korea unveiled research
on synthetic smart skin,
life-like ultra thin
crystalline silicon,
designed to cover
prosthetic limbs,
giving the user all of the
sensations of a natural limb.
They've now
developed a skin which
has touch sensors
embedded in it,
with a very fine matrix, which
can be put around a prosthetic.
So you can actually feel
what that arm is feeling,
or you can touch the floor,
feel whether it's hot or cold
or applying pressure.
Future artificial limbs
will look just like our skin,
look just like our
hands and our legs.
It's going to affect
the entire world.
We're going to see people
using smart prosthetics that
are added to the body
that can be controlled
directly through the brain.
And that really is the
future of prosthetics.
KEVIN WARWICK: I can speak
from experience because I've
had one myself, are implants
that link either into the brain
or into the human
nervous system.
And what I had was
100 small electrodes
fired into my nervous system
to link my nervous system
with a computer.
It was a bit like plugging a
plug into an electric socket,
but the socket was
my nervous system.
So I went to Columbia
University in New York.
We plugged my nervous
system into the internet
and I controlled a robot
hand from my brain signals.
You can extend
your nervous system
by simply plugging into it.
GRAY SCOTT: If we can use
just the power of our thoughts
to control artificial limbs,
we can eventually one day
use the power of our thoughts
to control avatar robots.